sit sit down in bed to nessa stein
I just feel Spencer final
this is a beast on the pinless
misaligned
for buying
Axl Bossa doing some soul-searching all
alone in a hotel on Germany's Baltic Sea
coast his latest single China or stones
is a very personal one the sun shining
in getting to know that one it's about
only being able to be happy when you
faced your inner demons and the
skeletons in your closet to get them out
in the open enlightening Kailash did it
once you've chewed all that over you
have the chance to liberate yourself
then gives the song start of the flight
design or glue pieces I the seven minor
Hendrick puts his dinafem Bossa is about
to embark on his first tour in two years
and as a season's live artist he's been
busy rehearsing with his band the
hamburg-based singer wrote some 60
tracks for the new album only 11 made it
onto the final release
it's VivaKi some Swedish it was
difficult to plan at the start an
Thurman but as it was my sixth album
when they thought I've already said so
much well then I despite all the
repetitions that you always get in the
lyrics it was my only chance of delving
deeper new songs and keep it again
speed a little seconds for the last four
years this villa in the Umbria region of
central Italy has provided the setting
for working on his new music his
producer Phillips danke has a recording
studio here giving the singer the
distance he needs to get his songs into
the right form
I'm under 50 min mark in two weeks you
can potentially get as much done as in
six months in Germany and its really
nice to then come home and say hey we
finished something so now I can forget
about it for three weeks and focus on
being a dad again or other things that
do me good design would have welcomed
folks Mamba semifreddo who'd what always
did was a good was music at the age of
17 he quit high school to follow his
calling after first singing in a band he
then went solo although his third album
was a commercial disappointment vasa
built up a substantial fan base with his
honest and unpretentious style
in 2013 he won the German TVs bundes
vision song contest representing his
home state of Lower Saxony
fans appreciate the substance of bosses
songs and his openness the book authors
been deployed if you really look at my
lyrics you will get a kind of insight
into me and I become and I think fans
have that young but it's not as if
people are staring into my bathroom or
kitchen the whole time or something like
that incidence inspired samoled any
coochie coo coo
after several months stuck in a studio
bossa can barely wait to play live again
guns often in limbo in this job it's
pretty normal to spend a lot of time in
the studio but not record that much
music and now comes what I call the
physical time the album is finished and
I can see my band mates again then we're
off to play live and be named cansado
bossa and his band's tour of Germany
Austria and Switzerland starts februari
29 he'll be a man back in his element
stylist time
Stein was dying
Stein own style